in West Kelowna BC an entire Community
is in mourning nine-year-old Isla Lawson
passed away in late November from an
infection related to the flu an
infection Isla's family believes wasn't
recognized by doctors until it was too
late are the Layla's gone but if by
her passing something can change to help
it doesn't happen to anybody else that
would mean a lot to my little baby
Canada's national flu surveillance
network is reporting five pediatric
deaths so far this season but that
number will soon rise with more
up-to-date provincial numbers suggesting
that at least 10 children have died from
flu related illnesses yes so we should
be alarmed and we should try to do
everything we can to reduce the numbers
the concern is you've had 10 pediatric
deaths and this is still very early in
the flu season and so you know we still
have several more months to go covet flu
and RSV have hit children hard all at
the same time leaving pediatric
hospitals struggling to cope with the
worst season since H1N1 first struck in
2009. I think that this is the busiest
I've ever seen it we're seeing larger
numbers in 2009 and certainly far
exceeding what we see most years at BC
Children's Hospital staff are preparing
for the possibility that single rooms
May soon need to accommodate two sick
patients instead of one the onslaught of
illness has already forced pediatric
hospitals across the country to cancel
surgeries and redeploy staff what I find
upsetting is that it's a
vaccine-preventable disease and that
we've had up until now low immunization
rates in children Public Health
officials are urging parents to get
their kids vaccinated against the flu as
soon as they can masking is being
encouraged too while there are signs
that the flu season may be peaking in
parts of the country the virus is still
very much a threat with hospitals
bracing for some very difficult weeks
ahead
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary